around 251 million years ago
the sun rose on the triassic period
although often overlooked the triassic
marked the evolution of some of the most
unique organisms in our planet's history
especially under the waves within the
waters of the triassic dwelt reptiles
with hammer-shaped faces
fish with buzz-saw-like teeth which
confounded scientists for centuries
and some of the largest and most often
forgotten
marine predators of all time so for this
entry into the archive
we'll be winding back the clock and
looking at the undersea organisms of the
triassic
the triassic period began with a global
cataclysm an extinction event known as
the great dying
caused by elevated temperatures and
oceanic acidification
resulted in over 90 percent of all life
in the oceans
including the long enduring trilobites
dying out
but in the wake of this great reset new
species emerged
growing to fill the abundance of
unoccupied niches
resulting in some truly surreal
adaptations
this is henodus a placodont from the
late triassic that
likely dwelled within the shallows
henotis like most members of its order
resembles a sea turtle
but isn't actually closely related
honotus was only around 1 meter or
3.3 feet in length and that distinctive
unwieldy shell on their back
was almost as wide as the creature was
long exactly why henotis
or any animal would develop such an
unusual shell
isn't fully understood but some have
theorized that the henotis's shell was
such an awkward size
because it made it difficult for aquatic
predators to fit their jaws around it
a very straightforward strategy but a
pretty smart one
aside from henotis the placodon order
during the triassic period also included
cyamodus
this genus also looks quite similar to
sea turtles
and might actually be more closely
related to modern turtles than henotis
was
unlike most species of turtles today
however which have just the single shell
for protection
siamotis had two separate shells one
shell protected its neck to its waist
while the other one protected its lower
hip region
the dual shells were likely an effective
defense against predators
and give sayamotis a one-of-a-kind look
moving away from the placodont order
also living along the triassic coastline
was the noteworthy mastodosaurus a
triangular headed amphibian
mastodon source had two distinctive
front teeth which likely helped it
capture prey
strangely however mastodonosaurus's
teeth were so long
that in addition to the animal's
nostrils there were two
extra holes in their skull which these
teeth fit
through when their mouths were closed
the mastodonasaurus's peculiar upward
facing
eyes also sets them apart from many
species
the unexpected ocular placement would
have been most suited for looking
upwards
suggesting the animal often fed on
organisms which dwelled on the land
and with the largest mastodonosauruses
reaching around
6 meters or 20 feet there's quite a lot
that would likely be on the menu for
this species
further out into the ocean we have an
animal which
for centuries baffled scientists meet
the helicoprion an animal with one of
the most unusual dental records in the
history of life on earth
the fish possessed a strange spiral of
teeth with most genuses possessing more
than a hundred teeth in total
when fossils of this tooth spiral were
first uncovered in the 19th century
paleontologists weren't quite sure where
on the animal
they belonged with some hypothesizing
the toothy spiral sprouted from the
animal's upper snout
like a really deadly nose by the mid
20th century it became more widely
accepted that the fanged swirl belonged
on the bottom jaw of the animal the
exact purpose of the spiral was still
unknown however with some speculating
that the toothy whirl could lash out
like a tentacle
to grab prey today most scientific
reconstructions place the spiral of
teeth further back in the animal's jaws
or perhaps even in its throat the most
prominent modern theory is that the
tooth whirl has something to do with
replicating old
teeth kind of like the system sharks
have and no despite appearances the
helicoprion is not a genus of shark but
instead thought to fall within the now
primarily extinct classification known
as the ratfish
a somewhat unfortunate name even more
unfortunate
helicoprion was already on its way out
when the triassic kicked off
we think a few species within the
helicoprion genus made it all the way to
the early triassic period but
sadly none of these buzz saw-faced fish
made it any further
and while we're talking about species
with unusual lips the atapu dentatus is
near the top
of that particular category older
reconstructions of this extinct genus of
middle triassic marine
animal are quite the site to behold at
first scientists believe
that unlike almost all other animals
atapidentatus's jaw was split down the
middle
with teeth running along the length of
this split as alien
and alarming as this might seem most
scientists thought atapu dentatus
used its unusual mouth for filter
feeding
using the toothed split to filter out
unwanted dirt
instead of to maim helpless creatures
new more complete specimens however have
demonstrated atapu dentate's split mouth
was actually a misinterpretation
and the head actually looked more like
this
the unusual wide mouth was possibly an
adaptation to better scrape algae
off the sea floor for consumption
although we can't say for certain
while this new atapu dentatus model is
less frightening than the old one
it's definitely just as unique looking
before we get to the true
giants of the triassic sea our next
group might be a bit more familiar
looking
these are the sauropterygia a
classification that first appeared at
the very start of the triassic
orders like the nothosaur navigated the
waters on paddle-like flippers
snatching fish in their fang jaw with
lunges from their long
neck the nostasaur lived a bit like the
seals of today
and were relatively small only reaching
3 meters or
10 feet in length by contrast the sword
to rygia classification eventually
yielded the much larger plesiliusora
a group which is much more commonly
known and the only branch of sorptarigia
to make it out of the triassic
most of the biggest and most famous
plesiliusora like
the leopleurodon live during the
jurassic period however
and maxed out at 6.4 meters or 21 feet
in length
quite the impressive reptile but even
jurassic aeroplesleosaurus seems
small in comparison to the true titans
of the triassic waters
meet the ichthyosaurus a diverse group
of reptiles with a long
and impressive paleontological history
ichthyosaur fossils were first
discovered
as far back as the 19th century which
led to some intriguing vintage artistic
interpretations of what these colossal
reptiles might have looked like
in particular marianning found various
nearly complete skeletons during her
lifetime
if you're not familiar with marianning
she was a pioneering english
paleontologist who made vital
contributions to the field though she
never got the credit she deserved
one skeleton inning found was that of a
temenodontosaurus an ichthyosaur genus
from
the early triassic in both their overall
body shape
and their long toothed beaks these
unique animals resemble the dolphins
while the two animals occupy a similar
niche they
aren't related and are just an
interesting example of two
different animals converging on a
similar body plan due to environmental
factors
unlike the dolphin however the
tomenodontosaurus got
much bigger ranging between 9 to 12
meters in size or
feet easily the largest organism on our
list so far
but the very largest of the ichthyosaurs
were in another class
altogether meet the shonosaurus a late
triassic genus
coming in somewhere between 15 or 20
meters
or 49 to 69 feet
what an incredible creature like the
smaller temenodontosaurus the
shonosaurus was also
likely a marine predator who hunted for
fish cethlopods and other forms of
smaller marine life after all there's
not much that was bigger than an
organism this size
indeed across the fossil record the
shonosaurus rivals many of the largest
modern whales with their sheer
bulk another way in which schonosaurus
was similar to whales
is that their ancestors and indeed the
ancestors of all ichthyosaurs
once lived on land before transitioning
to fully aquatic animals
carnitor heinz is a potential distant
relative of the ichthyosaur just
beginning the lanta ocean transition
process
while kartour heinz likely spent most of
their time in the water
it's been theorized that they could
still use their flipper like four limbs
to move on land
sort of like juvenile sea turtles unlike
many of the groups on this list
various species of ichthyosaur survived
beyond the triassic period
yet despite being the group's
evolutionary debut the triassic period
was the epoch in which the largest
ichthyosaurs reigned
this once again goes to show you that
the triassic while often
overlooked was an incredible era in
earth's history
and that's the end of our deep dive into
the oceans of the triassic period
this video was made as part of the
triassic themed week edge is currently
running so
go check out his channel if you haven't
already in the meantime
thanks for watching if you like this
entry please lend your support
and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious
see you in the next video
[Music]
you